is that that guy Robert again listen
concession stand girl
why don't you give me your number
wait you never said where he goes to
school I think he just works
[Music]
oysters come on
he has cats and his eyes are nice they
crinkle yeah because he's old
I think I really like him as promised
I'm not saying I will have sex with him
but I think he would like it why are we
having this conversation he's a terrible
kisser
listen to me call it a night hey do we
want to do this
is the worst life decision I've ever
made
I had a good time tonight
didn't you yeah
so what was his go-to move the reverse
squatting cowgirl where's cats at least
cute
I never saw them oh
why lie about having cats
because liking cats makes a guy seem
non-threatening
harmless he's hiding something
[Music]
I'm the monster in your mind
I need to keep someone away from me you
scared me
people choose to be scared
can't say I'm surprised to find lovely
ladies like yourselves in here looking
for protection Kelvin you need to shut
that down right now
what is the matter with you you
manipulated me
[Music]
so he called you
if you want to get along with a man
and not be alone your whole entire life
make peace
well little
discomfort
one of us has to die
I am
on